und jetzt sind ja eigentlich auch schon
genug zehnte sachen drin ich schubse
einfach in die richtung vor
meine lieben freunde wieder diese
begrüße ich begrüße euch recht herzlich
zu einer weiteren folge minecraft ex mir
wurden wieder sehr viele fake zugesendet
wenn ihr auf exakt findet ihr eine mail
zu senden können und in der beschreibung
aber bitte nur coole fällt zum heck
ziehen und nicht irgendwo gesehen hat
weil das kann nicht ich behaupten
sondern einfach leute schicken effekt zu
und ich nehme die dran oder nehmen die
nicht dran und ich weiß gar nicht was
hier wieder lag aber ich würde sagen wir
fangen mit dem effekt war ich wieder
ziemlich coole am start hat würde ich
sagen und ich will mich freuen wenn du
bist mein name anwendet und jetzt geht's
los der erste effekt wurde mit
zugesendet von justin bieber als justin
aber seinen nachnamen sag ich jetzt mal
lieber nicht wenn du zum beispiel einen
turm durch die wolken baust du unter der
wolke stehst und über der wolke eine
decke ist egal ob holz stein oder
irgendetwas anderes
siehst du trotzdem den sternenhimmel
also ihr seht hier ich habe den turm
gebaut wenn ich mal hier und schaue hier
ist ein turm davon ist schon testtour um
so ein kleiner kag stift ähnliche
unterschiede der turm ist extrem hoch
also der geht hier einfach hoch und ich
stehe jetzt die oben drauf und hierüber
mir sind die wolken und die fliegen hier
her und wenn ihr jetzt mal umschaut seht
ihr dass ich darüber eine kleine
plattform gemacht habe und durch die
plattform kann ich natürlich nicht durch
gucken ihr seht links und rechts davon
ist der sternenhimmel
wenn ich jetzt allerdings mal warten bis
eine wolke davor sie fast jeden moment
der fall sein die wolke kommt immer
näher und ihr seht was passiert und zwar
verschwindet dieses ding und ich kann
dadurch den sternenhimmel sehen das ist
eine extrem interessante sache
eigentlich und zwar wenn jetzt sofort
wird jeder denkt okay ich sehe die stehe
an et cetera da ist ja wohl nichts wenn
ich jetzt allerdings mal fliege seht ihr
da ist eigentlich sonne warnt aber wenn
ich unter der wolke bin sehe ich dieses
ding ist ich hoffe ihr seht dass ich
mach das mal nach ein bisschen heller
jetzt gerade seht ihr auch die wolke
verschwindet gerade wieder und jetzt
sehen wir auch wieder diese fläche
das heißt das ist ein bisschen krank ein
bisschen verwirrend gegen man kann quasi
durch brücke hindurch gucken dadurch
arbeiten fallen ganz cool effect und
jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich wieder
welche bedanke ich mich bei dir justin
für diesen richtig coolen fällt weil ich
fand im cool
wir bleiben auch gleich bei der nacht
effekt muss sich unbedingt bei nacht
passieren aber
ich mach das jetzt einfach mal auf nacht
gestellt weil man das wie ich finde
dadurch besser sehen kann und zwar bin
ich im chat und gebe mal dass hier ein /
effekt also schrägstrich effekt
leerzeichen game name also kommen
partner achtzehn99 also zehn sekunden
einen sprungkraft effekt auf alle
möglichst stärke und wenn ich jetzt hoch
springe einfach mal auch toll jetzt habe
ich doppel leertaste glücklich
vollidioten muss natürlich nur einmal
leertaste drücken wenn man so einen
sprung effekt also ich geb dir jetzt
noch mal ein so springen nach oben und
ihr seht jetzt durch die blubberblasen
jetzt sieht man nämlich ganz kurz mic
feld ich habe jetzt einfach mal einen
stopp gemachten screenshot damit ihr das
sehen könnt jetzt sind wir mal wieder
hier in der normalen welt damit ihr seht
ok kommen hier bin ich jetzt wieder ich
mache das ganze mal eben noch mal hier
im chat so springe hoch und blende euch
jetzt wieder anspringt dann wenn man das
ganz gut sehen kann und wer jetzt dachte
jetzt den screenshot und man kann
dadurch echt durch diese blubberblasen
durch kann man quasi die welt dann kann
es kurz sehen wenn man ganz hoch
springen dann kann man dadurch durch die
blubberblasen durch ein bisschen von der
microsoft welt sehen ich weiß nicht was
es bringt das ist auf jeden fall intakt
und danke an die panik der wir das
gesendet hat kommen wir zur nummer drei
der welt mit zugesendet von pudding dank
hd und wenn du schnee bla bla bla bla
ich zeige euch das viel lieber einfach
mal weiter so ein bisschen das komische
ist geschrieben hat ich mache einfach
mal ein loch beispielsweise durch muss
eigentlich nicht mal noch machen
übrigens tschuldigung das ist ein
bisschen mag ich bin noch am umstellen
zurzeit mit den 60 fps und alles möglich
und ich bin auch carola ob die fallen
deswegen kanzlei ruckeln wenn ich
beispielsweise schnee hin setzte zum
beispiel auf die höhe
dann laufe ich dagegen und lauft darüber
und ihr seht schon mit fünf wenn ich
dagegen laufe dann laufe ich auch
darüber sagt zwar ein bisschen ein aber
allen in allen gehe ich eigentlich schon
höhe also wenn ihr seht sneaker
beispielsweise sneaker den schnee hoch
und ihr seht schon ich gehör
wenn ich allerdings einfach mal hier so
ein bisschen schnee hinsetze und ich
stelle mich darauf und setzte jetzt ein
schnee dann sag ich automatisch ein das
ganze sieht man viel besser wenn ich
beispielsweise das ganze mal sieben hoch
mache also fast einen ganzen schnee
blocksperre mich rein und packt den
letzten schnee drauf ihr seht schon ich
fahr runter und bin komplett
innovativ kühlte wenn ich jetzt aus dem
schnee blog rausgeht kann ich da nicht
einfach wieder rein sondern wenn ich
jetzt drauf springen dann bin ich quasi
auch komplett drauf ist ein bisschen
komisch wenn die quasi auf schnee drauf
steht und ihr macht dann einfach den
letzten noch einen schneeberg drauf dann
sagt ihr ein bis sie wieder auf den
boden seit ist eine ganz interessante
sache danke an dich bedingt vierte sache
wurde mir zugesendet von helmut madness
die ich weiß nicht ob in wirklichkeit so
heißt aber wenn ja es ist ein richtig
cooler name weil dieses mit mc im namen
haben finde ich richtig cool heirate
mich bitte helmut jedenfalls seht ihr
schon ich habe hier einen rahmen und er
schreibt mir wenn du eine karte in einem
frame setzt und an block an dem der item
frame befestigt ist ab bleibt der
frommen mit der karte ca 2 sekunden der
luft stehen bevor er drop das ist
allerdings nicht nur bei einer karte so
sondern auch wenn ich beispielsweise
meineid im trailer dran setzt ich packte
einen eichenholz rein und kann ihn auch
irgendwie ein bisschen drehen hier und
jetzt schlage ich einfach mal den block
diesen befestigungs blocken weg werde
schon der frame bleibt ein bisschen in
der luft hängen jetzt nach 23 sekunden
roboter erst das ganze ist ein bisschen
komisch ich verstehe es auch nicht weil
wenn ich beispielsweise mal ein schild
nehme und dass daran an platziere was ja
eigentlich genau den gleichen effekt hat
mehr oder weniger ich packe jetzt mal
irgendwie item frameraten frame mit dem
grasbrook irgendwie hin und hier packt
jetzt mal ein schild hin wo ich
irgendwie drauf schreiben und ich
zerstöre den block an dem beide sachen
dran befestigt sind
dann fällt das schild direkt ab und der
item frame fällt erst ein bisschen
später ab ist ein bisschen eine komische
sache zwischen den beiden teilen davon
irgendwie zwischen rahmen und schiltach
keine ahnung warum ich mich der
wiedereinsteiger das war auf jeden fall
weg nummer vier und dann kann dich
helmut merken es die wert mitte mein
mann nein ich bin nicht schwul aber ich
finde den namen einfach ich gehe also
nicht helmut sondern es war der fünfte
effekt wurde mir zugesendet von dem
expeditors ich hoffe ich hab den namen
richtig ausgesprochen beziehungsweise
den ingame science fiction nahmen den
ich
ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine
jedenfalls ist das der grund warum ich
schon die ganze folgende 1.7.2011 und
deswegen ruckelt und 1.8 läuft jetzt
muss ich bei mir hat er lucky blogs blum
auf video gesehen wie cool das mit 60
fps kam das kann man relativ gut an mit
den 60 fps also jetzt einfach mal so ein
ding hier hin und bei den jetzt einfach
mal aber das hat mich im video zwei mal
so ein bisschen aufgeregt aber naja wenn
ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt könnt ihr
auf meinen kanal gehen aber jetzt machen
wir weiter mit jedenfalls ist es ein
fake über eine sache die gome hd gegen
mich bei dem app die mir gespielt
der oft angewendet haben zwar gräbt man
sich einfach 1 2 block tiefes loch
partie eine schiene daran die nein die
schiene soll so ausgerichtet sein zum
blog und zwar so horizontal waagerecht
da geht man in das noch ein hat dann
beispielsweise hier einfach mal einen
tnt nora am start und macht damit die
ganze zeit hier auf diese schiene
rechtsklick und ihr seht schon oben
bewegt sich ein bisschen was und da
kommen immer mehr komische pixel hatte
das ganze ruckelt ein bisschen und jetzt
gleich an mir da oben extrem viele tnt
sachen das heißt wenn ich jetzt hoch
fliegen und einfach mal das ganze hier
auseinander schiebe seht ihr schon als
vielleicht ein bisschen kacke dass das
ganze direkt ins wasser gefallen ist
aber ich kann das ja auch mal in die
andere richtung schubsen
jetzt sind da eigentlich auch schon
genug tinte sachen drin ich hab das
einfach in die richtung vor
ich bin nicht geflogen jung was ist da
denn bitte passiert man das ist einfach
so ich hätte nie gedacht dass das so
kratz gott oh gott oh gott oh gott waren
vielleicht doch ein paar mehr als zehn
tnt verloren aber naja
das ganze funktioniert nicht mit bier
ruckelt auch jetzt grad total das ganze
funktioniert allerdings nicht nur mit
tnt und sondern auch mit ganz normalen
loren also ich kann mich einfach mal so
ein loch graben kann hierzu eine schiene
hinsetzen die die natürlich wieder
falsch so toll wie ich das immer mache
und jetzt kann ich auch ganz normale
loren einfach drauf setzen sodass wird
er ganz ganz viele am besten haben damit
die ganze sich gleich schön aus der welt
raus banken jetzt gehen einfach mal hoch
schützen die an und setzen uns in einer
rein und jetzt die ohren fahren ok jetzt
ist doch weil wir jetzt gegen baum
fallen und jetzt irgendwann ihr hängen
bleiben aber ihr deutschen das ist sind
extrem coole sachen die man damit machen
kann
ich kann jetzt hier ganz ganz lange
darauf herum schlagen sich alle tnt und
dann irgendwie mal wieder eingesammelt
habe aber ich würde sagen meine lieben
freunde jetzt progressive auch schon
wieder also es mit denen mit dem dnt
loren ist echt eine witzige sache also
ich finde ja da könnten wir auf jeden
fall noch mal mit der tt und da ist auf
jeden fall noch irgendwie nachholbedarf
also das weiß auch nicht so viel was du
da gemacht haben aber ich würde einfach
schon mal die setcard machen und zwar
wenn es euch gefallen hat zeig mir doch
bitte mit einer bewertung weil viele
leute manchmal nachricht gibt dadurch
ein fake schon kart unfalls würde mich
freuen wenn ihr das video positiv
bewertet und mir per mail weitere cool
effect schreibt wie das coole mit den
sachen die mir das mehrheit komme zu
gesendet hat und ja sonst würde ich
sagen ich hoffe ich hab einen schönen
tag und ich war wieder ein großer
bin ich ein termin cooper villa im alter
wie krank ist das denn bitte